look know who used to put that boy in  the back of the net  [Music]  all right I'm Michael listen all right  I'm Ashley Cole and this is the football  not football first my challenge hey  don't kick my oh my good please that's  not bad luck that's not bad  okay so you can give it a bit more okay  now I know I'm scared I didn't want to  kick it I don't want to kick you don't  agree that guy Oh Mike nice that was  nice  that was very nice ah it's good get you  here yeah yes Mike it's good effort good  effort I'm gonna give it a bit now come  on - this is the one  ah I know that one was terrible to be  honest it's too far for me it's not my  game reference so we're going to take a  little bit closer  [Music]  ah oh I've done it he's done it he's  done it  that was the crosswalk challenge  congratulations go thank you like this I  want this yeah  spice it up I'm gonna smash this Wow  [Laughter]